más
[Música]
qué hay del otro lado del silencio
esta pregunta me acompaña hace mucho
tiempo y es un viaje hermoso por el que
me lleva es algo que cada vez me tira
respuestas tan interesantes como
curiosas pero sé que es algo que todos
aún sin saberlo ya lo sabemos
en el proceso de bajar las ideas para
esta charla nos invitan a todos los
oradores a un conversatorio sobre vida
consciente
vamos todos felices espectacular el tema
las charlas la gente y uno de los
oradores de ese día que hoy es maestro
de ceremonias
empieza a hablar sobre un tema que me
deja seco el lenguaje que utilizaba como
lo articulaba como la claridad de sus
ideas
darme cuenta que esta persona que no iba
a ser oradora tenía las ideas tan claras
me hizo hacer una cosa entrar en modo de
pánico
como decía nuestra compañera zona mágica
son abanicos ya estaba del lado de
afuera básicamente
el primer paso cuando entré en modo
pánico es que me desconecto y corto toda
conexión con la realidad porque
justamente de ahí viene esta sobrecarga
sensorial
segundo paso entre la hermana duda con
una patada voladora como la que hablaba
luis sobre su profesor a barrer
cualquier rastro de confianza que
pudiera haber
esta última crisis fue muy importante
porque me iluminó de una manera distinta
me enseñó que el último paso de mi modo
pánico que me viene un sueño terrible no
es tipo uno ya no me apagó no importa
quien tenga enfrente me ha tocado dejar
personas así que no entienden qué pasa
una vez una chica terminó conmigo y yo
me dormí la otra no entendía qué pasaba
la confusión fue para ella es perfecta
pero bueno esta situación me mostró que
mi cuerpo y mi mente han desarrollado
esta herramienta muy útil
que la ponen en práctica
cuando mi modo pánico
empieza a coquetear con su amante de
años
el estúpido y sensual autosabotaje
así nomás mi cuerpo y mi mente
decidieron que esta conducta
autodestructiva no va más y encontraron
la forma clara y contundente de
decírmelo así
es muy loco ver como
esta comunicación no es sólo en un
sentido no es solo que mi cuerpo me
habla mí sino que yo también puedo
hablar con él es un diálogo fisiológico
constante lo que tenemos en la vida
y todos
por más santos que seamos tenemos esa
voz en segundo plano que nos va
comentando en tiempo real toda nuestra
vida
queremos que eso ese fenómeno es la
intuición
y es una suerte de sensibilidad que
poseemos todos y ahora está intuición
es música
por qué
la música en teoría se divide en tres
elementos
ritmo melodía y armonía
el ritmo es una serie de sonidos que
suceden cada cierta frecuencia que
pueden variar en intensidad
a más fuerte o en duración de más cortos
más largos
la melodía se compone de todas las notas
de la ciudad
todas
y la armonía es la proporción adecuada
que hay entre todos los elementos de un
conjunto
porque esta inclusión es música
porque el cuerpo nosotros en la dualidad
física que representamos física del
cuerpo y abstracta en la mente y
conciencia de todo que somos se comporta
de la misma manera y está reflejado en
este mismo fenómeno
el ritmo en el plano físico nuestra
frecuencia cardíaca nos va marcando el
pulso en la vida en el plano abstracto
en nuestra respiración
la melodía en el plano físico en nuestra
voz vibración física en el plano
abstracto son nuestras emociones energía
en movimiento
la armonía en el plano físico en nuestra
postura
como nos alineamos con nosotros mismos
en el plano abstracto
en nuestra inteligencia emocional
imaginémonos una línea imaginaria
por eso nos la imaginamos porque se
imagina
donde van todas nuestras emociones desde
las más graves
la tristeza la angustia la depresión
hasta las más agudas la euforia la
felicidad la alegría
dependiendo de en qué emoción y qué
estado emocional estemos
van a subir ciertas frecuencias de esa
emoción si estamos tristes o deprimidos
vamos a tener un sesgo de este lado de
la línea imaginaria que nos estamos
imaginando
qué va a generar una especie de curva
esta curva
debajo de la curva estamos nosotros del
otro lado está el mundo
esta curva en particular es tan triste y
depresiva nos está sesgando nuestra
percepción del mundo no estamos mal lo
entendemos así porque así nos sentimos
en ese momento
ahora
esto es muy lindo con todo esto sí
salvador que poético la música la
intuición de qatar pero
cómo se conecta todo es muy fácil todos
ustedes todos nosotros los de arriba y
por no son públicos divino mi persona
todos acá todos escuchamos música y
hemos visto gente escuchar música y
siempre que hay algo de música alguien
reacciona sea el típico cogemos el
jueguito por el baterista matt el que
siempre está ahí marcando todo en su
falda en la mesa que vuelve loca la
familia que ya tienen ese
la música funciona así hay algo dentro
de ella que no vemos
que se comunica con algo dentro nuestro
que decodifica algo que nos hace
reaccionar y suceder en función de
de esta misma manera trabaja la
intuición solo que quizás nunca le dimos
la oportunidad
porque porque estamos acostumbrados a
que la comunicación siempre ha sido la
misma
afuera sentidos y percepción interior
ahora qué pasa cuando el mensaje o el
emisor
y nosotros mismos somos el receptor
hay pantalla azul y no entendemos pero a
medida que nos vamos entregando a esto
vamos entendiendo
este diálogo fisiológico del que
hablamos
lo vivimos todos los días y nosotros
elegimos qué tan parte de ello vamos a
hacer
el mensaje central
de la música
en prisión
es aprender a escuchar nuestra
respiración reconocer la melodía de
nuestras emociones
y alinear nuestras posturas y cuerpos
para que del silencio de esa armonía
surja la verdadera música
reconociendo así nuestra propia canción
ahora las tres con número dos todo muy
lindo salvador con tu mensaje pero como
hago yo si ya me estoy escuchando para
saber
cuando logre ese estado de armonía
el tema es el siguiente
si esta voz de la intuición que tenemos
nos invita a prender fuego todo y
reventar nos contra el mundo
podríamos seguir escuchando a selección
natural
a veces ahora sí esta voz nos invita a
conciliar ya resolver algo a desatar lo
que queríamos cortar
eso va a llevar un estado donde vamos a
sentirnos muy agradecidos por haber
encontrado esta válvula de escape sana
y es desde este agradecimiento donde
todo empieza a cambiar
porque desde el agradecimiento el mundo
empieza a sentir como que fluye de una
manera distinta una mejor manera
entonces
muy sencillo
qué hay del otro lado del silencio les
pregunto
nosotros
nuestra música
y es nuestra naturaleza como música que
somos escucharnos y fluir a nuestro sol
gracias
[Aplausos]